worum es sich bei der
bundespressekonferenz handelt nur zwei
vorbemerkung es ist keine
regierungsorganisation sondern ein
regierungsunabhängiger verein von
journalisten die über den bundestag und
die bundesregierung richten
und wir haben als hauptzweck die das
veranstalten von pressekonferenzen wobei
wir in diesem pressekonferenzen im
mitglieder in der bundespressekonferenz
und den mitgliedern des vereins der
ausländischen presse
das fragerecht einräumen dann beginnen
wir mit einem statement und einigen
vormerken von regierungssprecher hirns
seibert bitte schöner selbert ja vielen
dank meine damen und herren guten tag
es ist jetzt genau eine woche her seit
unser ganzes land angefangen hat die
maßnahmen umzusetzen die die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten in ihren erweiterten
leitlinien am 22 märz vereinbart hatten
das öffentliche leben ist stark
heruntergefahren millionen von menschen
bleiben zu hause haben ihr verhalten
völlig umgestellt unterlassen jeden
vermeidbaren kontakt außerhalb der
engsten familie es ist also zeit für
eine erste bewertung zeit zu fragen wo
wir stehen und die zwischenbilanz muss
ganz klar heißen und das kann nach so
kurzer zeit auch niemanden überraschen
wir brauchen alle maßnahmen und
vermindert wir müssen immer noch alles
tun um das virus auf seinem weg durch
deutschland zu verlangsamen die
ausbreitung zu stoppen ist im augenblick
nicht möglich aber unser ziel muss es
sein und kann es sein ihre
geschwindigkeit zu bremsen
und daran werden sich auch alle
entscheidungen ausrichten wie lange die
maßnahmen aufrecht erhalten werden
müssen
es wird immer um die eine frage gehen
entwickelt sich die zahl der infizierten
und damit auch die zahl der stark
betroffenen so dass unser
gesundheitssystem noch vor überlastung
geschützt werden kann
und das heißt dass alle auch die
behandlung bekommen die sie brauchen
weil es nämlich immer um menschen geht
und nicht um zahlen
derzeit ist es so dass die
geschwindigkeit der ausbreitung des
virus noch deutlich zu hoch ist um die
einschränkungen zu lockern
ob unsere maßnahmen eine wirkung auf
diese ansteckungsquelle haben und wenn
ja wie stark diese wirkung ist das
werden wir erst gegen ende dieser woche
bzw anfang der nächsten woche sehen
können
wir haben derzeit eine verdopplung der
fallzahlen etwa alle fünf tage wir
müssen schauen dass sich das mindestens
in richtung alle zehn tage besser noch
mehr entwickelt wir werden also
natürlich ständig die situation
überprüfen und glauben sie mir die
bundeskanzlerin wäre die erste die ihnen
auf fakt auf basis der fakten die
lockerung der maßnahmen verkünden würde
und zwar mit freude denn sie weiß dass
diese einschränkungen vielen menschen
zurzeit sehr vieles abverlangen dass sie
für viele menschen das leben schwierig
und sorgenvoll machen aber sie ist eben
genauso davon überzeugt es wäre
unverantwortlich hoffnungen zu wecken
die hinterher nicht erfüllt werden
können dann kämen wir vom regen in die
traufe und zwar gesundheitspolitisch
wirtschaftlich und sozial
es wird vorübergehen es wird eine zeit
danach geben wie gut diese zeit für uns
alle wird und wann sie kommt das hängt
eben jetzt entscheidend mit daran welche
geduld und welchen gemeinsinn wir
aufbringen
ich darf für die bundeskanzlerin noch
mal wiederholen was sie auch in ihrem
podcast am wochenende ausgedrückt hat
sie ist tief dankbar jedem einzelnen und
jeder einzelnen in deutschland die jetzt
so schwer es fällt die regeln einhalten
aus einsicht und aus fürsorge für ihre
mitmenschen und für ihr land und sie
bittet sie alle sie bietet uns alle
bleiben wir dabei ziehen wir mit es ist
im wahrsten sinne des wortes
lebenswichtig als sich dann dazu fragen
gleichen auto show
ich verstanden habe die entscheidung
also ich fange mal mit ihrer zweiten
frage an ja es wird am mittwoch so ist
es verabredet eine telefonkonferenz mit
der bundeskanzlerin und den regierungs
chefs und chefinnen der bundesländer
geben und thema ist dann eine
bestandsaufnahme der aktuellen lage der
ausbreitung des virus ich will noch mal
daran erinnern die kanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten hatten in dieser
einigung vom 22 märz auf die erweiterten
leitlinien die ich angesprochen hatte
eine geltungsdauer von mindestens 14
tagen festgelegt dabei hatten sie
bedacht dass bayern sich aus
geographischer nähe zu österreich und
auch aus einer ähnlichen betroffenheit
dem österreichischen zeitplan
ursprünglich angeschlossen hatte und
seine maßnahmen für 14 tage beschlossen
hatte für die mehrzahl der bundesländer
war klar am 22 märz das die leitlinien
zumindest einschließlich der woche nach
ostern also dem ende der osterferien in
den meisten ländern eingehalten werden
müssen
so drückt sich das dann auch in den
spezifischen länderspezifischen
anordnungen und allgemeinverfügungen aus
nun hat österreich inzwischen seine
maßnahmen verlängert und sie haben es ja
gerade gesagt heute mittag hat bayern
angekündigt die einschränkungen bis zum
20 april so zu lassen wie sie sind also
es gibt einen ein gleichlauf der
bundesländer und es gibt die besprechung
die gemeinsame am mittwoch dazu habe ich
online eine frage der bund werde mit dem
ministerpräsidenten mittwoch beraten wie
wird das ablaufen als video konferenz
oder telefonkonferenzen die presse
unterrichten
das läuft als telefonkonferenz ab so wie
auch die vergangenen male und wir werden
im anschluss die presse unterrichten ich
kann ihnen jetzt noch keine einzelheiten
darüber nennen aber das ist ja in den
letzten malen auch immer möglich gewesen
nächste frage kollege
ja ich habe ja gerade in meinen
vorbemerkungen gesagt was aus sicht der
bundesregierung der stand heute ist und
was die massnahmen dass die massnahmen
unvermindert weiter notwendig sind und
welches die überlegungen sind die für
die bundesregierung die entscheidenden
sind wenn es daran geht zu entscheiden
was ist der zeitpunkt um maßnahmen
wieder zu lockern oder aufzuheben
das ist dem kann ich jetzt hier nichts
hinzufügen eine bundesregierung und ihre
verschiedenen ministerien müssen sich
immer verschiedene gedanken machen
gedanken für den heutigen tag für die
nächste woche und natürlich auch
längerfristige gedanken aber ich habe
jetzt hoffentlich für die
bundesregierung klar gemacht was uns
eine woche nach inkrafttreten der
maßnahmen die schwere einschränkungen
für die menschen mit sich bringen was
für uns die lage ist und wie wir in die
nächsten wochen gehen
dazu passend vielleicht eine frage
holger schmidt denker von rtl frage
anhand seibert gegebenfalls auch als bmw
oder bmi burkhard jung präsident
deutschen städtetag fordert eine
differenzierte auslegung der ausgangs
beschränkungen
er sagt wir könnten zum beispiel
freizeitparks spielplätzen und kinos
wieder öffnen damit die leute wieder
mehr unternehmen können sagt die jungen
darauf bezieht sich der frage stellen
sieht darin keinen widerspruch zu den
regeln der bundesregierung wie ist hier
die beurteilung der regierung
ich habe gerade über die erweiterten
leitlinien die am 22 märz zwischen bund
und ländern beschlossen wurden
gesprochen und habe der überzeugung
ausdruck gegeben dass diese maßnahmen
unvermindert notwendig sind sowie sich
derzeit die ausbreitung des virus durch
deutschland darstellt
[Musik]
der minister hat er sich letzte woche
mit den führenden
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern getroffen
auch mit dem sachverständigenrat zur
begutachtung der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
lage die heute ja diese sondergutachten
vorgestellt
dieses gutachten war auch schon damals
teil des gesprächs minister hat damals
auch gemeinsam mit dem vorsitzenden des
sachverständigenrats wasser fällt eine
pressekonferenz gegeben in form einer
video-konferenz und hat dort auch noch
mal gesagt dass die auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaft
natürlich gravierend sind wir sehen dass
nachfrageeinbußen durch den stadtteil
wir haben probleme im angebote
lieferketten des staates das heißt wir
erleben hier eine sehr sehr massiv mit
sehr massive auswirkungen für die
deutsche wirtschaft und für die
weltwirtschaft insgesamt minister damals
auch gesagt dass er zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt von einer genaue bezifferung
des ausmaßes noch absehen muss weil die
datengrundlage guard noch sehr volatil
ist der minister wird sich ende april
dazu äußern
mitten im rahmen einer
frühjahrsprojektion da hoffen wir dass
wir auch schon ein bisschen besser mit
daten haben und was der minister aber
gesagt hat auf der pressekonferenz
damals und da hat er auch dem
wissenschaftlichen er nicht im sondern
im sachverständigenrat auch
beigepflichtet dass er davon ausgeht
dass wir eine eine an eine einbußen im
wachstum haben dieses jahr die sich auf
jeden fall auf dem niveau der
finanzkrise 2008 2009 bewegen
das mal so als richtgröße und alles
weitere werden wir in zukunft bessere
zahlen haben und dann auch dazu
kommunizieren vielleicht dazu passend
eine frage von nina jeglinski vom mbr
bayerns ministerpräsident müller hat
heute mittwoch einen notfall wirtschaft
gefordert ist das sinnvoll falls ja wie
soll das organisiert werden musste
wurden
darunter fallen frage ist ein niemand
speziell gerichtet vielleicht der
seiwert vielleicht das
wirtschaftsministerium hätte ja also wir
sind ja jetzt in einer situation wo wir
bisher im wesentlichen mit jedenfalls
was im rahmen der supermärkte sind da wo
wir lieferengpässen sehen aber bisher
noch keine schwierigkeiten der
versorgungssicherheit hat sich ja auch
die ministerin
klöckner dazu geäußert wir ansehen
verschiedenste auswirkungen das
verfolgen ist eine sehr sehr genau
gerade was das thema lieferketten
betrifft die ja nicht nur in was die
wirtschaft in deutschland betrifft und
sind ja auch europäisch und
international stark verflochten
das thema schauen wir uns ganz genau an
und sind mit dem unternehmen in kontakt
eine andere frage davon ist natürlich
die frage wie wir der beschaffung von
jetzt wichtigen medizinischen produkten
wenn es um die schutzausrüstung geht
wenn es auch um das thema arzneien geht
und da ist der krisenstab von bmi und
bmw und jetzt möglich das
gesundheitsministerium mit bei den an
dem thema dran insoweit können zeigt die
kolleginnen und kollegen dort nochmal
was ergänzen
was wir jetzt zudem in der speziellen
förderung von den bilder ergänzen
sollten die die beschaffung von
medizinischer ausrüstung
die läuft wir haben stand samstag
insgesamt 20 millionen masken
ausgeliefert an länder und kv die dafür
dann zuständig sind
die weiterzugeben an niedergelassene
ärzte pflegeheime und krankenhäuser
wir haben das haben sie vielleicht
verfolgt einen open house verfahren
aufgelegt also feste preise für
mindestabnahmemengen und hoffen dadurch
noch weiter
die beschaffung von schutzausrüstung
sicher zu können dann bleiben wir erst
mal ein gesundheitsthema so den direkten
gesundheitsthema hinterleitner hat sie
hatten auch einen fall gehen also wir
gehen nicht davon aus dass es zu
kurzarbeit und zu entlassungen kommen
werde wie an einem paket aufgelegt hat
was was finanzielle ausfälle von von
kliniken aus auffangen wird dafür dafür
haben wir keinen anzeichen dass es also
dass es dazu kommen zurzeit
bitte das läuft auf länderebene das
läuft nicht auf hunde sind dazu eine
frage von holger schmidt denker rtl das
bmg das klinikum in wolfsburg wir wegen
einer krone infektion beim personal
keine patienten mehr aufnehmen
welche pläne gibt es für solch einen
notstand wie wird die medizinische
versorgung und die arbeit in einem
solchen krankenhaus aufrechterhalten
ich weiß dass unbefriedigend aber
grundsätzlich ist die die
krankenhausplanung erstmal ländersache
und auch für solche fälle muss das land
muss die landesregierung dann
entsprechende maßnahmen ergreifen um die
versorgung aufrecht zu erhalten und das
kann dann sein dass patienten von von
dem einen standort zu dem anderen
gebracht werden das kann zusätzliche
kapazitäten seien die man an einem
standort aufbaut dafür gibt es
verschiedene alternativen die man sich
denken kann aber auch das ist nicht
zentral gesteuert weil wir genauso wenig
wie wir wie wir die urteile die die
situation vor ort direkt einschätzen
können in wolfsburg können wir dann auch
den lösungsweg aufzeigen das muss
regional gemacht werden und das ist
jetzt kein nachteil sondern das ist
eigentlich ein stern denn noch eine
frage von petra sorge dow jones die
ärztegewerkschaft marburger bund fordert
jetzt eine zentrale koordination für
eine produktion von schutzausrüstung in
deutschland einzurichten und notfalls
auch atemschutzmasken etwa in lackier
betrieben zu beschlagnahmen gibt es
solche planung bereits und wenn ja wie
weit sind diese ahrens bmg nein die gibt
es nicht
wir sind allerdings mit der heimischen
wirtschaft sind wir im ständigen
austausch es gibt auch die ganz ganz
hohe bereitschaft der wirtschaft beim
kampf gegen das koma virus mitzuhelfen
viele unternehmen fahren ihre produktion
hoch oder haben sie umgestellt zum
beispiel auf die produktion von masten
gerade in der textilindustrie das
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
aber diese reaktion dieser austausch mit
der industrie es weit sinnvoller als
jetzt irgendwelche planungs ämter
aufzubauen also in der krise eine neue
behörde aufbauen das halten wir nicht
für sinnvoll
ich will vielleicht ganz kurz nur
hinzufügen weil viele von ihnen ja
wissen dass es heute vormittag auch eine
ein treffen des sogenannten corona
kabinetts also besprechung der
bundeskanzlerin mit einigen ministern
und ministerin die von ihrer
ressortzuständigkeit her ganz besonders
jetzt engagiert und betroffen sind gab
und da war die beschaffung eines der
themen ein anderes war ein bericht des
gesundheitsministers über die
ausbreitung der des virus und über den
stand der des ausbaus der kapazitäten
und ein drittes thema waren
arbeitsstrukturen innerhalb der
bundesregierung wo wir jetzt ja nun nach
einigen wochen erfahrungen gemacht haben
und optimierungen vornehmen
nur die nächste frage herr jung und tun
sie mir bedingten feiern lassen mich
meine arbeit hier in ruhe machen und
gucken nicht böse wenn ich sie nicht
gleich daran nehme pardon aber das
versuche das hier irgendwie zu sortieren
herr jung bitte jetzt
nein aber es ist schwierig genug dass
hier zu koordinieren
gut es ist ja so dass neben den
beschaffungs bemühungen die natürlich
gesundheitsbehörden und krankenhäuser
machen auch das bmg eine zentrale
beschaffung aufgebaut hat darüber
verlieren und schon häufig berichtet das
heißt natürlich hat sich die
bundesregierung wenn sie wollen der
staat längst auch mit engagiert darf ich
nur mal kurz ergänzen der jungen die
frage damals war eine andere auf die ich
reagiert habe die frage damals war
obmann regelungen aufheben müsste um
produktionen zu erleichtern und darauf
war die antwort die sie zitiert werden
aber das nur am rande
das habe ich anders das habe ich anders
in erinnerung füge ich gerne gucke ich
gerne im protokoll nach müssen wir jetzt
hier nicht ausdiskutieren ja okay und
darüber hinaus will ich das noch sagen
dass das natürlich absolut richtig ist
was herr kautz gerade für das bmg gesagt
hat es ist richtig bei diesen
beschaffungs fragen auch da wo das bmg
sich sozusagen zentral engagiert
zusammen zu arbeiten mit der wirtschaft
in die wirtschaft hat die kenntnis der
marktteilnehmer die wirtschaft hat auch
die internationalen verbindungen um
notwendiges material zu beschaffen das
ist ja bisher nicht aufgabe einer
staatlichen behörde oder eines
ministeriums gewesen also ist diese
zusammenarbeit sehr nützlich also ich
kann dem auch nicht viel hinzuzufügen
die kollegen haben wir schon mal
ausgeführt dass gerade das bmg ist die
zentrale beschaffung macht und sich mit
den unternehmen engen austausch ist und
dort ist auch natürlich das thema
sicherlich sicherlich auch ein thema
die wie die versorgung sichergestellt
werden kann und zu welchen preisen das
erfolgen wird
bei dem nichts hinzuzufügen
die nächste frage herr meier
zunächst einmal müssen sie müssen sie
sehen was die österreichische regierung
da anordnet dabei geht es nicht um
medizinische masken wie sie erst und
pflegekräfte benötigen sondern es geht
um einen mund nasen schutz und das ist
etwas anderes wir haben wiederholt
betont dass es sinnvoll sein kann
andere davor zu schützen sich
anzustecken dass man dass man eine maske
trägt die nutzung von solchen masken
kann man in erwägung ziehen wenn wir
über ausgang szenarien
ausstiegsszenarien aus den ganzen
maßnahmen nachdenken
es gibt die industrie stellt sich schon
darauf ein
masken zu fertigen und das können wir
auch nur begrüßen wenn ich da auch so
etwas sagen darf
ergänzend sicher kann man sagen eine
maske vor dem mund kann in gewisser
weise dazu beitragen das
ansteckungsrisiko zu vermindern
aber natürlich für denjenigen der ihnen
gegenüber steht sie tragen die maske
dann ist derjenige ein stück sicherer
der ihnen begegnet und das hängt dann
auch noch sehr von dem verwendeten stoff
ab also es ist vielleicht eine sinnvolle
ergänzung zu den ohnehin geltenden
hygieneregeln und das muss man glaube
ich betonen abstand händewaschen kontakt
vermeidung das sind die wesentlichen
punkte und das tragen einer solchen
nichtmedizinischen maske darf eben nicht
dazu führen dass sich ein falsches
sicherheitsgefühl einstellt und man dann
beim abstand oder bei den hygieneregeln
insgesamt nicht mehr so aufmerksam ist
bitte dann habe ich jetzt nicht so von
der liste herrn tur zum stand der
bemühungen um die aufnahme von
schutzbedürftigen minderjährigen ist
glaube ich dass bmi in der federführung
genau ich kann fürs wegen die dazu gerne
etwas sagen der stand seit freitag
unverändert der bundesinnenminister hat
verschieden nicht betont dass
deutschland hier bereit es zu helfen im
europäischen verbund die kommission ist
dabei die gespräche zu führen
das läuft nach wie vor sehr intensiv und
wir hoffen dass wir wieder zeitnah zu
einer lösung kommen dazu schon also
diesen schulungen dieses wort
dieses wort zeitnah will ich auch noch
einmal für die bundeskanzlerin
unterstreichen sie hatte am donnerstag
nach der video konferenz mit dem
europäischen rat in ihrer
pressekonferenz noch einmal klar gesagt
das ist eine solidaritäts leistung die
jetzt möglichst schnell wirksam in der
praxis umgesetzt werden soll
denn jeder tag zählt die kommission
koordiniert das und arbeitet da intensiv
mit den griechischen behörden zusammen
und dieser prozess läuft weiter
herr seibert hat darauf hingewiesen dass
die eu kommission dabei ist das zu
korrigieren
die gespräche laufen es gibt es keine
konkrete hürde die man ihnen sagen kann
aber die abstimmung finden statt und wir
hoffen dass es jetzt sehr zeitnah eine
lösung geben wird
naja also dass für entscheidungen die
die griechische regierung zu treffen
hätte wir unterstützen griechenland bei
der versorgung der person die sich
darauf halten mit auf ganz verschiedene
art und weise das tun wir auf
europäischer ebene mit umfangreichen
finanziellen mitteln deutschland hat
zuletzt auch technische ausstattung
geliefert darunter 150 beheizte
multifunktions zelte um die situation in
den lagern etwas zu entlasten
und wir bieten auch weiter unter unsere
unterstützung an und sind dazu auch in
den griechischen behörden im gespräch
und die eu kommission ist das auch
nichtsdestotrotz ist es wie sie sagen
die lage dort in den hotspots ist sehr
angespannt
und gerade die unzureichenden
hygienischen und sanitären verhältnisse
machen uns auch sorge und deswegen
bleiben wir an dem thema dran
herr jung dazu
ich glaube die lage ist jetzt schon wie
ich gerade gesagt habe nicht so wie man
sie sich wünscht kann und sie ist durch
die ausbreitung des 19
regers verschlechtert die sich noch es
gibt muss man allerdings dazu auch sagen
dort bisher keine bestätigten corona
fälle unter den bewohnern der lage und
die griechischen behörden bereiten auch
notfall maßnahmen vor um die lage dort
so sicher wie möglich zu halten
also erstens gibt es dazu ja einen
beschluss aus dem koalitionsausschuss
das heißt alle in dieser bundesregierung
haben sich damit schon einmal befasst
zweitens habe ich gerade zitiert dass
die bundeskanzlerin dazu am donnerstag
ja auch etwas gesagt hat und natürlich
ist sie in einer so wichtigen frage in
ständiger abstimmung auch mit den
zuständigen ministern ganz besonders in
diesem fall natürlich mit dem
innenminister dazu auch direkt bitte
die eu kommission koordiniert und die
koordinierung und auch die gespräche
übernommen hat müssten sie dort
nachfragen an unserem stand gibt es neun
länder die sich beteiligen wollen
die jetzt aktuelle situation ist die
wahlkommission nachfahren ich kann ich
dazu ergänzen weil ich jetzt diese frage
heute unseren kollegen aufgestellt habe
und das ist bis jetzt glücklicherweise
so dass alle staaten die sich in der
vergangenheit dazu bereit erklärt haben
noch mal bekräftigt haben das sie trotz
der belastung durch den kronen virus
weiter zur aufnahme bereit sind gibt es
direkt jetzt noch weitere nachfragen
dann habe ich auch noch eine frage ans
auswärtige amt daneben wrestler von der
süddeutschen fragt außenminister maas
hat nur die noch nicht zurückgeholten
touristen um geduld gebeten wie viele
deutsche urlauber finden sich an orten
die als gefährlich eingestuft werden
müssen welche sind das warum konnten
deutschland unterschied zu bürgern
anderer nationen zum beispiel noch nicht
aus cusco peru zurückgeholt werden
werden also wir konnten seit ja die seit
beginn dieser rückholaktionen die läuft
ja morgen werden es zwei wochen seien
insgesamt über 175.000 menschen nach
deutschland zurückbringen entweder auf
von uns gestarteten flügen oder auf
flügen die in zusammenarbeit mit den
reiseveranstaltern und fluglinien
stattgefunden haben dass die die aktion
umfasst derzeit 43 länder insgesamt sind
sogar sechs aus 60 ländern deutsche
zurückgeholt worden auch in
zusammenarbeit mit anderen europäischen
staaten und allein übers wochenende sind
sieben neue länder hinzu gekommen
insgesamt über 1000 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter des auswärtigen amts die in
der zentrale und in den
auslandsvertretungen daran mitarbeiten
sie sehen also das ist ein enormer
kraftakt
es gibt in der tat in verschiedenen
ländern situationen wo der diese
rückholung nicht so schnell funktioniert
wie wir uns das wünschen würden
dafür sind die gründe von land zu land
sehr unterschiedlich das sind sehr
individuelle situationen teilweise geht
es um logistische probleme in ländern
die einfach über ein sehr großes
territorium verstreut sind
oft hat das mit ausgangssperren zu tun
dass es schwierig ist für insbesondere
individualtouristen die im ganzen land
verteilt sind überhaupt an die abhol
punkte zu kommen und dann gibt es auch
länder die im moment ihre flughäfen
völlig geschlossen haben dazu gehört im
moment beispielsweise neuseeland wir
wissen dass es dort eine ziemlich große
anzahl von deutschen gibt wir hatten
dort am freitag an die ersten rückflug
durchführen können aber seither sind die
flughäfen geschlossen und wir arbeiten
daran dass wir diese rückholaktion dann
hoffentlich bald fortsetzen können dort
sind nach unserer kenntnis deutschland
nicht unmittelbar in gefahr es gibt
andere länder wo landegenehmigungen
beispielsweise nur sehr reduzierter form
erteilt werden einfach aus dem bemühen
der regierung reisebewegungen möglichst
gut unter kontrolle zu behalten
dazu gehört der ruder werden
landegenehmigungen nur ein sehr
reduzierten takt vergeben in cusco
wissen wir gibt es eine ganze reihe von
deutschen die sich dort jetzt schon seit
über zehn tagen unter sehr strengen
ausgangssperren aufhalten das ist eine
sehr schwierige situation dort vor ort
wir haben aber für mittwoch und
donnerstag zwei rückflüge organisiert
und hoffen dass wenn die langgediente
genehmigungen dafür rechtzeitig erteilt
werden die dann auch durchgeführt werden
können und ein konsulat in unserer
botschaft in lima ist auch auf dem weg
nach cusco um die deutschen vor ort bis
dahin entsprechend konsularisch zu
betreuen und dann auch bei der
abwicklung dieser flüge zu helfen
da zwei jungen
wir haben über unsere auslandsvertretung
natürlich sporadisch darüber
informationen aber wir erfassen das
nicht systematisch das ist auch es gibt
ja auch keine meldepflicht für deutsche
im ausland sich bei uns zu melden
insofern werden kann können wir darüber
schon und deswegen keine vollständigen
und belastbaren informationen vor halten
das ist ja so eine sache jedes einzelnen
ob es sich in so einer situation an die
deutsche auslandsvertretung wendet oder
nicht dazu nachfragen noch herbig hatte
sich der bak hatte sich angemeldet
[Musik]
er wackelt haben sie verständnis dass
ich jetzt der besprechung der kanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten vom mittwoch
nicht inhaltlich vorgreifen kann außer
dass ich ihnen sagen kann sie werden auf
die lage blicken wie sie sich heute
darstellt in der ganzen fläche unseres
landes und werden sie bewerten und
daraus ihre schlüsse ziehen
aber das was an erweiterten restriktiven
maßnahmen seit dem 22
märz gültig ist das ist ja nun ohnehin
über diesen nächsten mittwoch hinaus
gültig in der ganzen fläche
nachdem nun auch bayern heute mittag
seine maßnahmen bis nach den osterferien
verlängert hat
mehr kann ich ihnen entschuldigungen
mehr kann ich ihnen über die
tagesordnung heute noch nicht sagen
gleichwohl noch eine frage die direkt
dazu pastor schmidt denke es ist den
vergangenen tagen mehrfach über tracking
apps dass wir gerade angesprochen so ein
witz und des virus gesprochen worden
gibt es da aufgrund ihrer möglichen
anonymisierung und ohne verwendung der
ortsdaten der handys nicht doch eine
möglichkeit der nutzung dieser tools
diese frage ist sowohl als bmg als auch
ins bmi gerichtet also es gibt ganz
unterschiedliche ideen zu dieser zu
diesen grundsätzlichen planen
dazu kann ich ihnen nichts im detail
sagen ich kann ihnen nur sagen dass eine
konsequente nachverfolgung von
neuinfektionen und kontaktpersonen
wesentlicher baustein sein wird wenn man
über exit szenarien nachdenkt wie das
ganze dann ausgestaltet werden kann
darüber unterhalten wir uns intern aber
das werden wir dann öffentlich machen
wenn es soweit ist
das bmi ich habe dazu keine ergänzungen
ist es jedenfalls nicht geplant wenn die
daten flächendeckend auszuwerten und zu
strecken im winter dazu
ja also zu ihrer ersten frage die
ministerin lamprecht hatte sich schon zu
antigone apps in der vergangenheit
geäußert und gesagt dass wir
diesbezüglich ganz genau anschauen
müssen dahin schauen müssen wie eine
solche handy-app im einzelnen
ausgestaltet ist und ob sie einen
sinnvollen beitrag zur bekämpfung der
korona pandemie leisten kann
sie hat betont dass zentral ist dass die
privatsphäre und die bürgerrechte der
bürgerinnen und bürger gewahrt bleiben
hier und deshalb sei in jedem fall
voraussetzung ist als solche app nur auf
freiwilliger basis verwendet wird und
alle beteiligten eingewilligt haben so
zu den voraussetzungen im übrigen kann
ich dazu nichts weiteres berichten
ich kann eigentlich nur das wiederholen
was ich gerade gesagt habe oder sie noch
einmal bitten in der tat noch mal nach
zu hören was der minister vergangene
woche in der in der
bundespressekonferenz gesagt hat hat er
nämlich auch gesagt das ist seiner
meinung nach wesentliche voraussetzung
dafür dass wir
dass wir die maßnahmen wieder lockern
können dass man nachverfolgen kann
besser nachverfolgen kann welche
kontakte infiziert haben ja aber in ja
nicht ist
wir tauschen uns ja schon aus wenn wir
vorschläge machen und das machen wir als
bundesregierung gemacht
sie wissen ja sie wissen ja wie diese
wie dieses gesetz zustande gekommen ist
in welcher zeit in welchem zeigt unter
welchem zeitdruck und das war dann im
austausch bevor es ins kabinett gekommen
ist dass wir gesagt haben okay
dafür müssen wir längere zeit noch
diskutiert das tun wir zurzeit dann
ziehen wir das zurück und machen das bei
einem anderen zu einem anderen zeitpunkt
konkret wegen wir etwas neues vor
er war ja dazu
ich kann ihnen zu den details noch nicht
sagen weil die noch nicht stehen naja
wenn sie es ist ein unterschied ob sie
jemanden fragen ob er sich erinnert wen
er vor 14 tagen getroffen hat und oder
ob sie eventuell sagen okay er hat eine
app die auf freiwilligkeit beruht eine
variante die ja ausgetauscht hat mit
ganz vielen anderen und dann guckt man
sich die daten an
wenn das funktioniert flächendeckend
aber das sind das sind noch noch sachen
die in der diskussion ist dass das
können wir nicht bewerten und
kommentieren
die jungen dazu
wir haben alle modelle im blick und
werden alle modelle aus dies die es
zurzeit gibt genau das dazu direkt jetzt
noch weitere nachfragen dann kommt muss
ich noch mal auf den aspekt der
wirtschaft zurückkommen frau kunz von
der rheinischen post fragt werden die
kosten für die krise über
steuererhöhungen oder sonderabgaben
mitfinanziert werden müssen wird es also
ein lastenausgleich geben müssen wie
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg oder der
wiedervereinigung
also ich kann ja mal kurz anfangen und
aber herr kolbe sind da sehr bekommen
die bundesregierung hat in so kurzer
zeit wie noch nie und mit soviel geld
wie noch nie
maßnahmen ergriffen und der bundestag
der bundesrat haben diese maßnahmen
beschlossen um unseren unternehmen zu
helfen um arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und
immer in dem versuch die unzweifelhaften
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen die wir
schon jetzt erleben und die natürlich
auch noch stärker werden abzufedern
einzudämmen aufzufangen und in diesen
maßnahmen war jedenfalls nicht von
steuererhöhungen die rede
und deswegen kann ich ihnen jetzt
einfach nur sagen dass es das woran wir
jetzt arbeiten und das drückt sich in
diesem wirklich umfangreichen
gesetzespaket aus ja das kann ich nur
noch mal unterstreichen die
bundesregierung hat erhebliche maßnahmen
ergriffen da ist auch genau auf diesen
aspekt auch geachtet worden dass es
sozial ausgewogen ist und dass die
hilfen eben auch die erreichen die sie
besonders notwendig haben wir haben ja
dieses soforthilfeprogramm für
kleinstunternehmen aufgelegt es gibt es
kurzarbeitergeld um eben beschäftigte
und kleine unternehmen jetzt schnell zu
schützen darum geht es im moment um
schnelle
unbürokratische krisen hilfe zu leisten
und alle weiteren punkte werden wir
erörtern wenn es so weit ist
der minister hat ja auch schon
angedeutet dass wir uns auch über die
konjunktur dann gedanken machen müssen
wie wir die wieder in schwung bringen
aber diese maßnahmen wenn wir dann
werden wir die krise bestanden habe dazu
der minister hat ja immer wieder betont
dass er auch dafür ist die abschaffung
des soli die schon beschlossen ist für
den großteil der steuerzahler
vorzuziehen auf mitte dieses jahres an
dieser forderung hält er fest
gerade unter den umständen die wir die
wir jetzt haben und das hat er jetzt
mehrfach betont das kann ich auch hier
nochmals bekräftigen
da geht es wieder um den sozialen
ausgleich
das haben wir ja schon betont als wir
die abschaffung des soli für 90 prozent
der steuerzahler auf den weg gebracht
haben
das trifft jetzt die dies besonders
dringend brauchen
es gibt immer noch kosten für die
deutsche einheit die wir tragen müssen
die müssen bezahlt werden
die abschaffung für die restlichen teil
der steuerzahler also für die die sehr
gut verdienen würde noch mal und mehr
kosten als das paket dass wir jetzt auf
den weg gebrachter nämlich über zehn
milliarden euro
und das haben wir genau aus diesem grund
der sozialen ausgewogenheit eben nicht
gemacht weil es weiterhin noch aufgaben
gibt und deswegen wollen wir jetzt die
unterstützen die hilfe besonders
notwendig hat herr jung besucht
in den nachrichten geben
erst an diesen
ich ihre frage ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
aber ich werde es versuchen also
zunächst einmal die erste frage ich kann
ihnen zusätzlich zu dem was wir gesagt
haben keine weiteren finanzpolitischen
überlegungen der bundesregierung bieten
ich habe dazu keine neuigkeiten für sie
die wie solidarität mit den menschen die
jetzt betroffen sind schwer betroffen
sind in der wirtschaft die solidarität
mit kurzarbeitern mit solo
selbstständigen mit arbeits mit mit mit
angestellten und allen arten von
menschen drückt sich in dem großen
maßnahmenpaket aus dass jetzt
beschlossen wurde
und ich habe keine weiteren
finanzpolitischen planungen für sie
das andere ist ihre frage in richtung
europa die europäische zentralbank ist
zunächst einmal und das ist auch sehr
wichtig dass das auch so bleibt
politisch unabhängig deswegen
kommentiere ich nicht irre ihre
maßnahmen die ergriffen hat in europa
gibt es eine intensive diskussion
darüber die auch beim europäischen rat
im video konferenz format letzten
donnerstag geführt wurde wie man dafür
eintreten kann dass die wirtschaftlichen
folgen des corona virus in den griff
bekommen werden kann dass die menschen
geschützt werden können die unternehmen
genau das was wir auch national machen
und da ist beschlossen worden sie können
das in den schlussfolgerungen sehen dass
die europäischen finanzminister weiter
ihre arbeiten betreiben sollen
vorschläge vorlegen sollen binnen 14
tagen das ist also dann in der
übernächsten in der nächsten woche
entschuldigung in der nächsten woche
ende der nächsten woche die deutsche
überzeugung ist dass der esm ein
kriseninstrument ist dass wir beim
letzten mal erst schaffen mussten als
die krise kam und dass der esm
instrumente hat mit dem wir mit denen
wir arbeiten können um genau die sorgen
die nöte der europäischen
volkswirtschaften aufzufangen und dass
daran jetzt gearbeitet wird auf basis
der europäischen finanzminister ist aus
unserer sicht sehr gut
da muss ich sie ehrlich gesagt
korrigieren im europäischen rat der
staats und regierungschefs herrscht
einstimmigkeit hätte es gilt jetzt mal
ganz grundsätzlich es haben sich viele
länder in vielen situationen schon zu
wort gemeldet haben gesagt dass sie
etwas nicht mittragen ich will dass nur
als grundsätzliche bemerkungen es
herrscht einstimmigkeit weil sie es so
darstellen als wäre das im europäischen
rat anders ich kann ich ja auch noch mal
ergänzen weil diese gespräche über den
finanzministern laufen also es ist ganz
klar es gibt jetzt eine große
herausforderung für europa und auf diese
herausforderung werden wir eine
europäische antwort geben deshalb die
staatschefs so geschlossen deshalb die
finanzminister auch schon zum teil
umgesetzt
die maßnahmen haben wir hier auch schon
ausführlich besprochen also die der eu
haushalt wird so umgestaltet dass
erhebliche milliardenbeträge für hilfe
zur verfügung stehen bei der beihilfe
beim stabilitätspakt wird was getan
bei der eib werden zusätzliche maßnahmen
gefahren um gemeinsam in europa
solidarisch durch diese krise zu kommen
die ezb hat erhebliche maßnahmen
getroffen
jetzt geht es darum wie schnell und
effektiv weitere maßnahmen ergriffen
werden könnten da sind wir uns alle
einig in europa das ist schnelle und
effektive und solidarische hilfe geben
muss und dafür ist der esm geschaffen
worden er steht bereit diese funktion zu
übernehmen
der minister hat dazu auch am sonntag
auch ja in ihrer sendung ausführlich
schon gesprochen und gesagt dass wir
solidarisch unseren partnern in europa
zur seite stehen
solidarität in europa drückt sich auch
noch auf andere weisen außen ich finde
auch das kann heute mal erwähnt werden
es vergeht kaum ein tag an dem
beispielsweise und
unsere bundeswehr nicht dazu beiträgt
das schwerst betroffene corona patienten
aus italien oder aus frankreich in
deutschen kliniken überführt werden
können wo derzeit noch die kapazitäten
dafür da sind
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
teil europäischer und sichtbarer teil
europäischer solidarität vor wir zur
herwig kommen nur die informationen
versorge und verliert ihre frank komme
auch gleich herbig ich weiß nicht ob sie
da nicht was völlig falsch verstehen es
ist es sind die schlussfolgerungen des
europäischen rates der 27 mitglieder
staats regierungschefs des europäischen
rates vom donnerstag
die finanzminister erneut zu beauftragen
das ist nicht die bundeskanzlerin das
sind 27 staats und regierungschefs und
über die politische unabhängigkeit der
ezb
die nicht durch
jedenfalls nach unserer festen
überzeugung nicht durch einzelne
regierungen beauftragt werden kann dies
oder jenes zu tun habe ich mich auch
schon geäußert
[Musik]
auch wenn ein europäischer rat im video
konferenz format stattfindet gelten für
uns jedenfalls weiterhin die grundregeln
der europäischen räte nämlich dass sie
vertraulich tagen insofern kann ich
ihnen das sagen was in den
schlussfolgerungen gemeinsam beschlossen
wurde und was wir jetzt zur frage von
auch wirtschaftlicher und
finanzpolitischer solidarität gesagt
haben
[Musik]
aber ich muss nicht dann komme ich zur
erfahrung von petra sorge dow jones news
die wirtschaftsweise ist sich bei der
frage der korona bonds ja uneinig der
ökonomen achim truger waren etwa vor
einem kollaps des euro wenn die schulden
nicht vergemeinschaftet werden sie die
bundesregierung angesichts der
unsicherheit der experten inzwischen
auch die notwendigkeit ihre ablehnung
gegen euro-bonds zu überdenken frage an
den seibert und gegebenfalls
wirtschaftsministerium ich kann nur noch
mal auf die schlussfolgerungen des
europäischen rates das ist ja gerade
erst drei vier tage her verweisen
denen hat auch deutschland zugestimmt
und nun ist es wichtig dass die
europäischen finanzminister ihre arbeit
machen weil schon nächste woche ende
nächster woche sie ja ihre vorschläge
präsentieren sollen ich kann nur noch
mal sagen worum geht es denn es geht
darum jetzt schnell und effektiv hilfe
zu leisten
und genau dafür ist der esm geschaffen
worden um solidarisch die zu
unterstützen in europa die hilfe
brauchen und genau auf dieser basis
können wir auch schnell hilfe leisten
dann habe ich noch eine frage von julia
leigh faz frage das bmwi mittelständer
beklagen eine förderlücke wollen direkte
zuschüsse auch für unternehmen mit mehr
als zehn mitarbeiter sind änderungen in
diese richtung geplant
ja wir haben ja einen umfassenden
rettungsschirm geschaffen mit zusammen
mit den anderen beteiligten ressorts
sondern im bundesfinanzministerium der
verschiedenste komponenten vorsieht
wir fördern und unterstützen unternehmen
vom solo selbstständigen bis zum großen
unternehmen haben wir verschiedene
institute dafür zur verfügung wir haben
heute in kraft getreten und ab heute
auch über die länder beantragt bar sind
die sogenannten sofort helfen das sind
tatsächlich zuschüsse die je nach
unternehmensgröße bis zu 15.000 euro
betragen für drei monate und die sind
für unternehmen bis zu zehn
beschäftigten darüber hinaus haben wir
einen umfang umfang umfassendes
kfw-programmen indem wir mit mit einer
unbegrenzten garantie in unbegrenzter
höhe dort kredite zur verfügung stellen
in der wirtschaft ist auch vom
kleinunternehmen bis zum großen
unternehmen dort wird von der von der
dort werden auch stark nachgefragt wie
aktuelle zahlen habe ich glaube ich
irgendwo hier genau das sind glaube ich
stand freitag 8,2 milliarden euro
beantragt worden und davon über 95
prozent der anträge von den über 700 40
anträge sind für im volumen im
kreditvolumen von bis zu drei millionen
euro das sozusagen kleinste kategorie
beantragt worden
was zeigt dass das nicht nur ein
institut ist was große unternehmen zur
verfügung kommt sondern gerade auch vom
mittelstand nachgefragt wird und dort
auch ankommt daneben haben wir und das
hat auch minister stolz diese minister
scholz minister altmaier hier
vorgestellt den sand wirtschaft
stabilisierungsfonds wo wir auch nochmal
mit den drei säulen auch großen
unternehmen helfen können aber auch
kleinere unternehmen
denn wenn bestimmte voraussetzungen
vorliegen dass wir wirklich ein
umfassendes programm das ab heute jetzt
auch mit dem sofortprogramm zur
verfügung steht dass wir mussten jetzt
werden wir gucken uns natürlich auch
laufen dann wie sie wie die programme
nachgefragt werden was es geht dem fast
schwierigkeiten
aber wie gesagt der möglichen
umfassenden rettungsschirm gibt
vorgestellt der garantien von üblichen
rund eineinhalb billionen vorsieht
50 milliarden euro das dass das
sofortprogramm dazu noch das
kurzarbeitergeld das natürlich auch
gerade beim thema im lohnzahlung in
unternehmen eine sehr sehr große hilfe
ist in diesen zeiten und daneben haben
wir noch über das finanzministerium die
die steuerstundungen damit wir gerade
auch über den die stundung von
vorauszahlungen gerade auch noch mal die
notwendige qualität in den unternehmen
lassen können und diese schwierige phase
zu überwinden
also wir sind da sehr sehr breit
aufgestellt aber nichtsdestotrotz
beobachten wir alle entwicklungen und
schauen uns das ganz genau an projekten
dazu
wir haben alles dazu gesagt also es geht
darum schnell und solidarischen hilfe zu
leisten
da wurden schon erhebliche maßnahmen
ergriffen um gut durch die krise zu
kommen gemeinsam in europa gemeinsam mit
unseren partnern
jetzt geht es darum wie die
kreditaufnahme unterstützt werden kann
dafür gibt es den esm
und da ist man jetzt im gespräch wie das
geld dorthin kommen kann wo es gebraucht
wird und schnell und effektiv und genau
über diese punkte sprechen wir mit
unseren europäischen partnern mit den
finanzministern und werden dann den
europäischen staats- und regierungschefs
einen vorschlag machen
ich möchte vielleicht auch noch mal zu
dem punkt wo er mehrfach jetzt hier die
euro-gruppe so herausgestellt wurde das
ist ja ein ganz normaler vorgang
die euro-gruppe hat davor auch schon
dieses paket beraten und hat auch davor
in form des euro gruppen vorsitzenden
die staats und regierungschefs
informiert von daher gibt es da
überhaupt keine abweichung zu dem
üblichen vorgehen dass hier an der zeit
ist
der kollege aus dem finanzministerium
hat die antwort gegeben und er habe ich
nichts hinzuzufügen
frau müller dazu
[Musik]
ja vielleicht noch mal kurz zur
einordnung ich hatte eben genannt dass
die zahl die sich nochmal wiederholt
hatten 8,2 milliarden euro nochmals in
ordnung da sind wir beim
kfw-sonderprogramm 2020 das ist das
große kreditvolumen wo wir gesagt haben
wir ein bis zu 800 milliarden
kreditrahmen das was minister altmeiler
minister scholz vorgestellt haben glaube
seit 13 monaten in der
bundespressekonferenz wo dieses
grossvolumige kreditprogramm verkündet
wurde dort haben wir jetzt 8,2
milliarden euro beantragen und über 700
ich glaube ab 750 anträge sind das
daneben steht das zuschussprogramm dass
diese 50 milliarden
das startet wie gesagt ab heute wir
gehen davon aus dass eine große
nachfrage ist man muss auch sagen dass
es sehr groß dimensioniert als 50
milliarden euro ist es ist viel geld wie
gesagt maximal sind das ja 15.000 euro
die pro unternehmen ausbezahlt werden
können
und ach guck man es natürlich jetzt
genau an wie die abrufzahlen sein werden
aber wie gesagt jetzt muss man erst mal
abwarten das ist wie gesagt heute
gestartet wie dann die abrufe sind aber
die nachfrage das hat auch sich bei uns
schon gezeigt im vorfeld wir haben das
jetzt mit hochdruck jetzt alles
erarbeitet die nachfrage wird sicherlich
hoch sein aber zahlen habe ich das
natürlich natürlich noch nicht
vielleicht kann ich das noch ergänzen
die länder selbst tragen auch erhebliche
teile dazu bei deswegen in der
pressemitteilung haben wir auch noch mal
aufgeführt welche landesbehörden
ansprechbar sind für die einzelnen
unternehmen und bei diesen
zuschussprogramm werden durch die länder
zusätzlich zu dem bmf und bmw programm
also der bundesregierung noch erhebliche
zusätzliche leistungen erbracht und das
sollte man auch berücksichtigen wenn man
fragt wie umfangreich ist die hilfe die
ihr geleistet wird
vielleicht wenn ich noch mal ganz gut
sie ergänze weil die frage dann
vielleicht auch mal die fragen die hand
die frage noch mal für alle die uns auch
oft erreicht wer ansprechpartner ist
ansprechpartner für das sofortprogramm
es nicht der bund sondern es wird auch
die länder
administriert der bund
hat gemeinsame der länder dort eine
verwaltungsvereinbarung zur durchführung
des programms geschlossen und in der
regel sind das die landesförderbanken
wir haben eine pressemitteilung
veröffentlicht gestern dass auch unsere
website dass er noch mal alle
ansprechpartner aufgezählt wie die
einzelnen länder wo die anträge gestellt
werden können das in der regel
landesförderbank man die sich dann
antragsteller wenden können ich muss
kurz und ein stück mache mir selber
signalisiert hat muss er fünf nacht weg
das heißt wir arbeiten jetzt diesen
komplex hier ab und dann müssen wir auch
schluss machen
es war jetzt offen die frage nach den
[Musik]
ungerechtfertigten der anspruch
genommenen hilfen ja vielen dank für die
frage vielleicht kurz zur einordnung zu
diesem themenkomplex die minister
lambrecht hatte sich jüngst zu dem thema
geäußert und noch einmal betont dass es
nicht akzeptabel ist wenn finanzierte
unternehmen ihre mieten nicht zahlen
und sie hat zudem betont dass die korona
hilfs gesetze die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben dafür auch keine
grundlage bieten
es gilt weiterhin mieten müssen gezahlt
werden sie müssen rechtzeitig gezahlt
werden wenn sie bei fälligkeit nicht
gezeigt werden entstehen auf
verzugszinsen oder können entstehen und
falls unternehmen oder sonstige mieter
tatsächlich infolge der krise in
zahlungsschwierigkeiten geraten kann
ihnen lediglich bei den begrenzten
zeitraum nicht gekündigt werden
gerichte können das auch überprüfen im
einzelfall ob diese voraussetzungen
vorliegen und die ministerin hat in
diesem zusammenhang auch noch einmal
betont dass man gut beraten sind wenn
sie sich mit ihren mietern
zusammensetzen einvernehmliche lösungen
zu suchen um diese hätten ja wenn es
total schwierigkeiten kommt wir
beobachten natürlich diese lage geraten
diese dynamische lage weiterhin wie sich
das risiko neuer krisen sich auswirkt
sehen aber derzeit keine weiteren
gesetzlichen änderungen vor die sind
nicht geplant
zusatzfrage dazu vermindert oder dann
die letzte von den jungen dazu bitte
na ja also wir hatten ja miteinander zu
tun so ist ist okay für mich war das
eine frage von durchaus fragen gibt es
bedarf an die anderen spreche da können
wir gerne so verfahren erwartet war weg
und dann stellen sie jetzt ihre
zusatzfrage nochmal zum
justizministerium bieten im einzelfall
jetzt nicht kommentieren
das ich kann mich jetzt sagen nur auf
das beziehen was in dem das die
kündigungs- oder was wir im gesetz dort
geregelt haben und das betrifft eben die
kündigung also die die aussetzung der
der kündigungsmöglichkeiten für drei
monate stundung regeln können natürlich
noch individuell getroffen werden
zwischen vermieter und mieter aber das
ist eben einzelfall abhängig und kommt
ja auf den jeweiligen der beim
mietvertrag zu setzen
also die man muss das differenziert
sehen also die mieter müssen ist erstmal
nicht nachweisen aber im rahmen einer
gerichtlichen überprüfung glaubhaft
machen dass sie aufgrund der allgemeinen
kroner situation oder aufgrund der
zahlungsschwierigkeiten eben die mitte
nicht entrichten konnten und das ist
eben auf corinna beruht das heißt wir
haben auch hier natürlich eine
möglichkeit das gerichtlich überprüfen
zu lassen
das ist sache der länder das kann ich
jetzt nicht kommentieren weiter fragen
dazu erwartet neues thema
ja man muss vielleicht dazu sagen dass
diese dass diese helfen ja nicht nach
dem gießkannenprinzip verteilt werden
also man muss einerseits bei den
krediten sehen diese kredite das ist ja
der große teil gesagt das große café
sonderprogramm auch der der wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds
da geht es ja um kredite dh unternehmen
müssen kredite aufnehmen verschulden
sich und müssen dafür zinsen bezahlen
das ist ja das sind ja in schulden und
verbindlichkeiten den unternehmen
bleiben wenn es ein unternehmen nicht
aufnehmen muss ist natürlich diese haben
die natürlich auch insoweit durch den
vorteilen die andere frage ist mit dem
mit dem sofortprogramm die wo es
tatsächlich um zuschüsse geht die nicht
zurückgezahlt werden müssen
dort ist aber auch geregelt das
natürlich eine gewisse dass das
dargelegt werden muss dass eine
liquiditäts schwäche besteht dass gerade
aufgrund der fortlaufenden
zahlungsverpflichtungen insbesondere was
die miete etwa betrifft wenn ich
gewerbemieter bezahlen muss und
plötzlich keinerlei einnahmen habe dass
ich diese weiter dass ich diese weiter
bezahlen kann das heute auch noch mal
ganz wichtig ich muss als
gewerbetreibender dort vielleicht
beantwortet ein bisschen die frage dort
versichern dass ich aus meinen laufenden
einnahmen
diese laufenden ausgaben nicht bezahlen
kann und deshalb liquiditätsengpass was
ich nicht machen muss ist dass ich mein
komplettes vermögen vorher aufbrauchen
muss und bevor ich diesen antrag stellen
kann
das heißt wenn wir unternehmen haben ja
wie gut die jetzt wird vielleicht mit
mit mit rücklagen da stehen die an beide
jeweils die gleiche die gleichen
anspruchsvoraussetzungen das heißt dann
können sie die laufenden
verbindlichkeiten die sie haben aus
mieten aus anderen dauerschuldverhältnis
die dort ja nochmal genau aufgeführt
sind können die beglichen werden
aus den laufenden einnahmen und wenn
nicht dann besteht der anspruch auf die
soforthilfe unter noch den ein oder
anderen weiteren voraussetzungen aber
dass
zum grundsatz weitere fragen zum ganzen
komplex förderprogramme freuen
es gibt die möglichkeit dort auflagen zu
machen
das sieht sowohl das wirtschaft wird
gerade wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds
gesetzt dass ihm ausdrücklich drin dass
man natürlich die möglichkeit hat dort
auflagen zu machen was die
dividendenausschüttung geht anbetrifft
hintergrund ist natürlich dass nicht
sein kann dass man helfen gibt einem
unternehmen und dass diese helfen dann
als gewinn ausschütten
das ist der zweck dann der einzelfall
geregelten maßnahme so ich hab mir ist
jetzt ein neuer und herren war weg ich
habe jetzt gerade mal so umgestellt dass
ich bis 14.15 bleiben kann doch nur bis
kurz nur zwölfter nicht schamlos
ausnutzen gelegen
gut fand wieder mit der zweiten frage an
wir hatten ja in der vergangenen woche
gesagt dass die bundeskanzlerin anfang
dieser woche sich nochmal einem corona
virus test unterzieht und wenn da ein
ergebnis vorliegt werden wir sie wieder
darüber unterrichten in allen fragen der
dauer der quarantäne richtet sie sich
nach den empfehlungen der ärzte und des
robert-koch-instituts ziemlich doch den
ersten teil vergessen also die die die
basis der der zahlen
na gut das robert koch institut das kann
der kollege aus dem beben gehen noch
besser sagen legt ja regelmäßig zahlen
vor aus denen zahlen über die über die
neuinfektionen zahlen über die bereits
genesen und dann kann man aus diesen
neuinfektionen natürlich ermessen in
welchem zeitraum eine verdoppelung
stattfindet das ist für uns das
entscheidende es ist natürlich auch
immer noch im zusammenhang mit anderen
fragen zu sehen also im zusammenhang mit
der situation in unseren krankenhäusern
mit den kapazitäten die dort vorgehalten
werden können im ausbau der kapazitäten
das sind natürlich elemente die man
gemeinsam betrachten muss
was was ist heute für ein neuer stand
genau und wenn das ergebnis vorliegt
wenn wir sie darüber informieren
wie in der vergangenen woche er war weg
dann bitte ich ihm die letzte und kurze
frage bitte dazu ist von dieser stelle
am freitag alles gesagt zusatz bitte die
zitate können sie in den protokollen
nachlesen
und das ist meine antwort darauf doch
hoffen
ich habe ihn ganz ganz so der sprecher
des bmi gesagt hat können sie den
protokollen nachlesen ich habe den satz
trat zweimal gesagt das reicht noch
nicht aus
danke dann sind wir für heute am ende
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für die
aufmerksamkeit und bleiben sie gesund